well it is officially that time of the
year sleigh bells candy cane and old
saint nick
but one houston mom is teaching the
importance of representation this year
and is making sure that all the kids in
texas feel seen this holiday season
i love this story and this person so
much take a look
hi my name is megan butler coleman and
i live in houston texas
i am the owner and the founder of a
company by the name of the black santa
houston and i founded the company about
three years ago in 2019 for my son luke
it's amazing how children change your
lives for me all i wanted to do was have
an opportunity for luke to take a photo
with santa when he was 10 months old and
little did i realize that i wasn't
actually going to be able to find
exactly what i was looking for a person
that was a reflection of my family and
that had a natural beard
after a search for
more than two years when luke turned
almost three years old i was able to
connect with a very very dear friend of
mine oni and we were able to start b
black santa houston and now
straight from the north pole we have
created this amazing experience and a
new tradition in houston where all
families have the opportunity to meet a
santa that is reflection of their family
and that just provides a little
additional christmas cheer to a time in
which we have a very you know standard
image that we usually see of santa but
we are allowing for all families to see
themselves through santa through the
black santa houston honestly for me it's
just it has me over the moon and we
honestly
want to celebrate christmas every day
megan butler coleman is joining us now
via zoom
megan how are you
so good hi
megan
you are just my hero i mean what started
off as a photo session for your son has
grown into something so meaningful
for so many people in the city of
houston
please tell us
you know
what your intention was
thank you so much drew
i don't know why it wasn't here in
houston or just available to all the
families but i'm just so overjoyed and
excited that we were able to create an
experience for families all over houston
and even in cities beyond and
beyond photos i just have to you know
tell a very special thank you to our
photographer because he's able to help
capture these moments and these magical
moments with the families
that are just traditions that are
lasting
and now we even have mrs claus joining
us and so santa's on the road he's
traveling to cities like colleen texas
to hospitals we even have families drew
flying in from seattle and oklahoma
louisiana just to come and have an
opportunity to just have that magical
moment it just it just overjoys me it's
just so exciting
i don't know how
this is not a standard norm
i think what you are doing is so
revelatory i want to see you expand it
beyond texas thank you for everything
you are doing in that state but i'm like
how can we help you
build this out because what you have
built is so incredible
thank you
wonderful
it's just wonderful thank you so much
for doing this now i think it's time
actually to meet santa can we bring him
out
[Music]
[Applause]
this organization to me is so
groundbreaking and mind-blowing
that i don't know how it's not in every
city across the globe
and how do we get there because you see
over 500 children in houston
and may i ask as the start the seed of
this most important journey that you and
megan are doing how do we take this all
the way because it's just so important
drew
actually it is the joy of the magic of
christmas you know we want to have our
families to have traditions that they
love and part of that tradition is to
have our kids to take pictures with
santa so that's some of the things that
we've talked to megan about and that's
something that we've been doing for just
three years but it's getting bigger and
bigger and it's so much more than the
picture it's a tradition that families
really value
oh and you're
this means so much to me and you've had
such a big impact on the city of houston
what have you learned
from that
model
that we think we can take elsewhere
drew i've learned that we have to make
sure that kids at a very young age they
begin to see images of themselves
regardless of their color race or creed
that's very important so when kids say
mommy i want to be a doctor daddy i want
to be a teacher
when they see those images really young
it's a reflection that they can actually
be that one day so the sooner they start
to see those images the sooner they can
know that they can actually do it and
they can become exactly what they want
to be
if you see it you can be it absolutely
now i hear you do so much charity work
um and have a
local outreach program um coming
so i would love to let you know that we
want to give you guys five thousand
dollars to help
buy toys for all the kids
we thank you and love you so much drew
for what you're doing for helping us to
spread the word of how important
diversity is in a diverse world i am in
awe of what you guys do it is an honor
to talk about your program and let me
help expand it thank you santa
and thank you megan i can't wait to do
more happy holidays we'll be right back
[Music]
you